تسلق جسر متحرك لجذب الانتباه
إلى نفسه ، تشبث رجل غامض
بالشبكة المعدنية بينما مرت السفن والقوارب من
جسر ميامي بريكل في الوضع الرأسي ،
ما الخطأ في
كرة ديريك الجديدة هذه التي التقطت هذا الفيديو من
سطح منزله عندما وصل المتسلق إلى القمة
وأنا أذهب على هذا النحو لا يمكن أن يكون حقيقيًا ، يجب
أن يكون مجنونًا لأنه شق طريقه ببطء إلى
أسفل بعض المشاهدين الذين شعروا بالذهول ، فأنا أعاني من نوبة
هلع وأنا أشاهد هذا ، فإن راحتي
تتعرق حرفيًا كان هناك قارب
يمر في البداية بدأوا في
التصفيق  يرتدي رجال الشرطة أشعة الشمس الحارة في ميامي ، مما
يجعل الأعمال المثيرة مثل هذه أكثر
خطورة من خلال تسخين السطح الفولاذي والخرساني
عندما كان في منتصف الطريق أسفل الجسر
وبدأ في النزول وارتفعت ذراعه
في مضخة القبضة
وبدأت في التلويح كما لو كان
يقود  قسم البوق
عندما كان الجسر مستويًا بما يكفي ،
وقف المتسلق منتصبًا وركض في
الوقت الذي وصلت فيه الشرطة ، لقد ذهب في
نفس اللحظة التي توقف فيها ديريك عن تسجيل
المتسلق الذي نزل على الأرض لفترة وجيزة ،
ستكون مثل تمرين الضغط
واختفت للتو  هذا ليس
جسر شارع 59 في مانهاتن الذي
غنى عنه سيمون وغارفانكل ، لكن متسلق جسر بريكل
يبدو أنه [
موسيقى]
رائع بما يكفي لأخذ قوس
نيويورك
[موسيقى]